the Joe Rogan experience I like how
gross you out
this year I'm telling you sometimes just
the other podcast we've done with I'd
stop in the middle of dangle [ __ ] yes
some of the [ __ ] thinking well mostly
about the tragedies mostly about your
childhood
it's funny now Joe it's just that I took
uh you know I say on stage I said um uh
when you when you when you can laugh at
what you've been through then you got
control of it it's only reason why I can
laugh about being shot and I even my
husband hate this bit I do I do a bit
about my first case father you know
giving me crabs gonorrhea fleas no toy
[ __ ] fleas I mean people get crabs I
get it but when someone gives you fleas
like what the [ __ ] but back in those
days the health department would come
and pick you up and say hey you [ __ ] on
five we need to put it out no you don't
gave somebody else crap gonna release a
recent report everybody he was messing
with and I was always on that list oh
Jesus I was like how can you tell people
that I think it's funny that they used
to come get me and me and the health
department man had a relationship now we
want sleeping together here's a hey puss
it was on in this again but I was young
you know it was suppose she gonna read
your shouting hands and I remember they
came one time Joe you know they knocked
ona doing it I said oh my god you here I
thought you don't let me burn up he's
like you put on this I'm here to put it
out
[Music]
so my hair's not what he would say
what'd he say you [ __ ] on the list
it's pretty much he would call it your
[ __ ] he said you [ __ ] be reported oh
my kid's father was there I was like
let's go together and get carries on I
don't want to go somebody might see me
so this is what he told me say look it
was gonna write when you're gonna ready
to get a shot or you take pills for
seven days so he said look going to the
health department but don't get the shot
getting the pill so we can split them so
I'm so stupid I come back and split the
seven-day pills when we still both
gotten all the way so like why why you
tell people he's [ __ ] everybody
always think he gave me gunner and shot
me and beat me like you please daddy
people I didn't do this [ __ ] to you how
does he deal with you having this act
like when you go on stage and talk about
all this [ __ ] how does he handle it does
he cover his ears he never he only seen
me once wait what
he won't come see me Joe come on he
wouldn't he came to see me we can't
William accent when I was opening up for
can tweens and but that's the only time
when he he's got to know oh you know
funny as [ __ ] like how does he not want
to see that you don't want to see a job
well the coming come to the comic store
tonight he's gonna be there for the
10:30 show you don't watch your [ __ ]
podcast and tell my daughter oh she was
so [ __ ] funny but he's not gonna
director to say to me he was so [ __ ]
funny he's my biggest cheerleader I mean
I mean you know I've been doing this 17
years you know how many time ahead it
makes that man credit card out to go and
do it so you know but he would not come
see he's like look I live with you I
hear this year every day but he gives me
like he's funny to me like I told you
saying not today I was yeah not at all
he say some of the funniest [ __ ] but he
you know I can't believe he's only seen
you do comedy once though one time out
of 17 that's a good one though open for
cowboy